what's going on guys this is Rob and did
you know that in Marvel Comics man thing
owes his entire existence to Captain
America we're going to talk about
whether or not they're going to put that
in the MCU in this video because in this
video we're talking about how amazing
werewolf by night was which by the way
normally this would go on geek culture
explain but I'm giving the staff over
there a few weeks off so we're putting
it up here on Comics explained werewolf
by night was phenomenal and I'm not even
gonna lie to you guys I kind of feel
like this is what phase four should have
been to be honest with you all right
World building and that kind of thing
technically we did get Wanda Vision
which was Nine episodes we got Loki
which was six episodes and they did a
lot of work in terms of expanding what
some of the characters that we were
familiar with were capable of
specifically Wanda the Loki's building
the Multiverse but beyond that I don't
think we needed like a nine episode I
think it's nine episodes a season of
She-Hulk honestly I think this would
have been great just a series of
One-Shot episodes like specials if you
want to call them that that basically
introduce us to new characters that we
otherwise never would have seen or heard
of in the MCU having said that this show
was phenomenal it was perfect in almost
every way it had everything I mean as
perfect as you get when it comes to the
MCU like by the time you got to the end
yeah it was really formulaic it was your
Marvel Cinematic Universe formula that
we've seen time and time again which is
really starting to grow old and we're
really noticing it now more than we ever
did before but this show was great it
was absolutely well done first things
first I loved the black and white
aesthetic God that just made it so cool
and it followed the horror theme perfect
it really felt like the old George a
Romero's Night of the Living Dead if you
guys ever saw that movie not the one
with Tony Todd but I'm talking about the
original the old black and white one but
this just had this great just sort of
like 1960s 1970s black and white horror
aesthetic which is really cool because
that's kind of the genre that werewolf
by Knight fit into when it came to
Marvel Comics those guys who don't know
where will find Knight was the attempt
by Marvel Comics to bring back the
horror genre the way that the kind of
nature of comics worked back in the day
is like you started off with superheroes
when Superman was first introduced then
superheroes stopped being popular so you
wanted to science fiction and then they
started blending superheroes and science
fiction but it's part of that science
fiction popularity you saw the horror
genre becoming really really popular now
at the time guys like Spider-Man started
showing up Superheroes Were the name of
the game but there was an effort to kind
of see if there was a way to bring that
horror element back and like Swamp Thing
Man thing werewolf by night they were
all attempts to do that Swamp Thing of
course was a DC thing but still there
were attempts to do that and there were
others as well right blade and Michael
morbius and so on and so forth but the
important thing that I'm talking about
here is that in relation to the show it
really had that great horror element it
wasn't over the top it wasn't like
terrifying but it did have that kind of
spooky you know like they're coming to
get you you know that kind of feel and I
absolutely loved it oh my God I loved it
having said that Elsa Bloodstone was
great and I really want to see more of
her in the MCU absolutely I want to see
more Elsa Bloodstone and the great thing
about this right the great thing about
this blade we know hopefully fingers
crossed maybe is going to get a movie
it's been pretty rough
air in the blade landscape and turns
them being able to just create a film
based on the character like the director
just left with like two months before
they're supposed to start shooting the
film so and apparently they're like
reworking the script and everything so
it's been a rough it's been a rough go
of it but the cool thing is that what I
think this show is going to do for just
the general Marvel Cinematic Universe
audience and maybe even just the general
movie audience is this going to give
people a desire to see the Monster side
because as a comic book fan I'll tell
you right now where monsters dwell uh
Monster Island all that kind of stuff
it's really cool like like the whole
monster side of Marvel the whole like
darker evil midnight Suns even Doctor
Strange to a degree right with this
1990s run of the Defenders a lot of
those things were really really awesome
and there's just some like untapped
potential when it comes to what the MCU
could do with that so I really hope they
decide to build on this and to have kind
of like two themes running at the same
time where like the TV show is one part
origin one part like all the monster
stuff and the movies kind of stay in the
movies where they kind of do their own
movie thing occasionally dipping into
the monster side but what I also want to
talk about here is I want to talk about
werewolf by night and I want to talk
about man thing now I'm not going to
give any spoilers to what's going on
with either of these characters in
either of their story arcs but what I
will say is they have some development
werewolf by night has development really
just knocking everything else out of the
park I love the whole thing right like
the character of Jack Russell and like
the actual werewolf Persona I loved it
all and here's one of the here's one of
the best things about this one of the
best things about this whole thing right
it it wraps it all up in just one nice
neat bow but the whole thing
self-contained right so you don't need
to know anything else about the MCU in
order to appreciate this right you sit
down you watch the show you know it
exists in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and that's enough everyone that you're
going to see in this show is brand new
you've never seen these people before
you've never heard of them before it's
one 100 self-contained and that's why I
say I really hope it all makes sense for
those of you guys who are hardcore comic
book fans of Elsa Bloodstone the
Bloodstone itself and really the role of
Ulysses follows almost Rank and file
with the comic so you can certainly just
be like yes like I am so excited to see
that because there are some hardcore
fans of Elsa Bloodstone and Ulysses
Bloodstone that are out there watching
this show that being said the properties
of the Bloodstone are exactly the same
as they are in the comics uh I don't
know if it's really any kind of a
spoiler but basically it just grants you
a variety of different powers some of
which are more attuned to being a
monster hunter than anything else but
the fact remains like there's a lot of
really cool elements here one of the
things that I wish they had done and I
understand why they didn't do it and
they don't really need to but one of the
things that I wish they would have done
is kind of expand a little bit more on
the other monster hunters who were there
all you're really told is that they're
people who hunt monsters and that's it
and admittedly that's all you really
need to add that Exposition in you would
expand the length of the show from being
an hour to being an hour and a half
honestly that probably would have felt
like a little too long but before we
talk about man thing and the the Captain
America relationship in the comics what
I want to do is I want to kind of wrap
back around in the beginning and I want
to say this is what phase four should
have been this is really what it should
have felt like a series of just one
shots right for those of you guys who
aren't familiar with Comics this show is
the equivalent of a One-Shot comic
that's it a backup feature if you want
to call it that or something like that
something that's not tied into anything
and just tells you a story about a
character and you know they exist in
Marvel but from start to finish it's
completely self-contained and you're not
left confused about what's going on in
relation to like everything else if at
the end of werewolf by night you're
confused because you're asking yourself
the questions like where are all the
superheroes and where's this character
and where's that character and so on and
so forth you're confusing yourself
there's no reason to concern yourself
with like where any of the Avengers are
or where this takes place in the
timeline or anything like that it
doesn't need to answer those questions
it's introducing you to characters and
that's it and they could have done that
out with She-Hulk they could have done
that with like anybody else that they
wanted to bring in I mean if they wanted
to offer more explanation on the
character of like Taskmaster or if they
hadn't even given us Taskmaster in Black
Widow and they wanted to introduce us to
Tony Masters this would have been a
great way to do it this has endless
potential right like it's just so easy
to follow and this is exactly what phase
four should have been hey guys here's a
character here's the information you
need to understand the nature of this
character we'll explain their background
story later have fun and like that's it
and that's that's all you really need it
would have been great having said that
let's talk about man thing and let's
talk about Captain America so in Marvel
Comics one of the things to know is that
when Steve Rogers was made into Captain
America as most of you guys know
probably from the MCU the super soldier
serum died with Abraham Erskine there
was no conceivable way for anybody to
duplicate that exact serum but a lot of
people tried and one of them was a guy
named Ted and so what Ted had done is
that in the attempt to reverse the
nature of the captain America super
Soldier see him which seemingly he was
about the closest that you got right the
closest to actually getting a tried and
true Captain America Super Soldier see
him but in an attempt to duplicate that
his work was basically discovered and
ultimately funded by Advanced idea
mechanics now in the MCU Advanced idea
mechanics was in Iron Man 3 they're
totally different from the comics and
the comics Ames started off as Hydra
science Division and then broke off and
formed their own thing but basically
once Ted had realized that aim was
trying to get a hold of his research and
knowing they would use it for nefarious
purposes what he did is he injected
himself with the only known duplicate
orb as close as you can get to the
duplicate of Captain America's super
soldier serum and then destroyed all the
documentation showing how to make it and
then jumped into a lake which had
magical properties in the original
telling of the story and then the
magical properties combined with the
super soldier's theorem turned him into
man thing now in later years they
basically said that he made a deal with
the devil so I don't know which one you
really want to believe honestly it's
whichever one you want but cool thing is
that can be explored in the MCU right
you can explore that relationship that
Ted was a guy who was trying to copy
Captain America's serum and things went
awry and ultimately he ended up becoming
the person that he was I don't know if
they're ever going to give us that
backstory but the important thing here
is that this show was right it was
absolutely phenomenal it was it was just
beautifully shot they even included the
little transition things those guys who
don't who aren't aware of that when you
were watching the show you will have
noticed from time to time up in the top
right hand corner this little round oval
would just flip in right it would just
just like that that's a signal to the
theater to transition the film right to
put in a new piece of film so the movie
can continue on that's how they used to
do it back in the day now they didn't do
that here this whole thing was shot
digitally but it's cool that they added
the small little unnecessary Aesthetics
in order to give it the feel that it was
shot back in the day the attention to
detail was phenomenal in this show it
was great in this show but I love the
environment I love the overall area I
loved the maze the whole thing was cool
right but again I am really really
excited to see where we end up going in
the direction of Elsa Bloodstone Jack
Russell werewolf finite and the man
thing I'm really excited to see where
their stories take us in the future of
the MCU but with that being said guys
let me know what you think down in the
comments section give me your thoughts
your opinions did you love it did you
hate it and I will catch you all later
peace